so can you tell us a little bit about
this new technology and how it actually
interfaces with the standard prosthetic
limb so we bring in the standard
prosthetic limb and because sensation
hasn't been available most of them don't
have sensors on them and so we basically
have added this lab system on the top
where we can record or sense how much in
pressure a person is putting on an
object when they grab hold of it and
then that is recorded on a computer
converted into a neural code if you will
a neural stimulation and then we run
that through a set of wires that go in
in the upper arm and then underneath the
skin they go to a cuff electrode that's
then placed around each of the nerves in
the in one of our subjects in the
forearm and the other one actually in
the upper arm and how do you modulate
the current going through the electrode
in order to give that sense of touch we
actually think that's one of the most
interesting parts of this work that
we've done is that when we began
stimulating with the very regular
pattern of pulses people would feel the
sense of touching something but they
would describe it as a tingling as a
paresthesia if you will so like your
hand waking up in the morning that pins
and needles effect they liked it because
they felt their hand they actually were
very encouraged about that we wanted to
get a little more sophisticated and so
we've done is we begun varying the
strength just slightly and and what we
believe we're doing is that we are then
changing the the activation of different
axons in different ways within the hand
and so that information then is
translated to the brain it interprets it
as a more natural input as opposed to
this abnormal regular pulsing we have
placed electrodes around each of the
three main nerves that go to the hand
which are the median ulnar and radial
and so the median has the first three
digits at the hand the ulnar has the the
ring finger and pinky and the radial has
the back of the hand and so around each
of the nerves we've placed eight little
electrical points and when you turn
those on each of them gives us unique
location on the hand so what type of
tasks can the amputees now do with their
prosthetic limb which they couldn't do
before one that we we're pretty certain
of now are things like delicate tasks
for example we look at cherries when in
the nice thing about cherry even though
it's sort of visual is that if you
squeeze too hard it crushes if you don't
squeeze hard enough you can't pull the
stem out and so even with vision they
weren't able to perform that task
particularly well when we turn sensation
on they were able actually to do it
almost perfect every time so it makes a
big difference where they can do it the
other thing that they couldn't do before
which is very interesting is just feel
somebody else's hand and you know when
we asked our subjects what do you really
want to get you know functions great but
they want to hold for example their
spouses hand and when we would talk to
some of the the subjects or their
spouses they would say you know I don't
let them hold my hand because it hurts
and so now when they get the sensation
they feel touching something and so
that's what they've been looking for is
just that that interaction the human
interaction of touch again which is how
we interact communicate and explore the
world this is the first long-term study
2a shown sensation over I believe two
years right correct so that's why we're
really excited as well is that there's
been reports of other interfaces that
that have given sensation but they've
been short-term and this is the first
time it's been applied and showing that
where they feel the sensation has been
basically the same for the last two
years so we believe that this is a
long-term repeatable reliable interface
to the nervous system and apparently
this new technology also helps with
phantom limb pain which I believe is a
major problem for amputees yeah both of
our subjects came in and said that they
would have debilitating pain you know it
can imagine your hand one who described
it as a vise that would continue to
crush his hand until the fact he felt
the fingers were gonna go through his
palm they said keep going until they did
and then you can't you can't rub it
that's just not there so it's just pain
and so for us we didn't study pain per
se but both of our subjects have
reported that since we've done the
stimulation they've basically 90 95
percent or virtually pain-free they
don't have that any longer and they've
been very grateful for that and so what
are the next steps for you and your lab
and this fascinating new technology
right so the first electrodes we put in
we mentioned eight contacts around each
nerve that was that was just a low
number we wanted to get to see what we
could do so we believe because every one
of those was unique that we can begin to
increase that number of electrodes
around there and the way we do the
stimulation so we've taken these
stimulation patterns they go to touch
and we
seen that we can get more complex
sensations we're actually working with
colleagues to get really understand that
and take that to the next level where we
can maybe feel silk or sandpaper or
whatever they have to be touching and
then the last thing we're doing is this
has been in the lab and you know it's
really interesting one of our subjects
one time decided as he was leaving the
lab he says you know as he was taking
his process with him he says well I hate
leaving my hand here it's kind of
interesting the fact that he wasn't
going to feel his hand was what he's
referring to so even though he had a
tool the prosthesis he didn't feel like
he had his hands so we want to get to
the point where they can now take
sensation home with them system they can
use outside of the laboratory
environment and every day dr. Tyler
thank you so much for joining us today
and congratulations on a landmark paper
thank you